and viva las vegas the sponsors of this
next segment is back at the orleans this
weekend and the festivities kick off
today so you know it's there you gotta
send jc if it's a party send jc he's
live with more on the rockabilly weekend
hey jc in
cars yeah those two things yeah there's
cars out here that that that's right
that's right daddy oh that's right daddy
oh i'm trying to work my rockability and
daddy oh and talk like that this is tom
he's the one that puts on the event
we're so happy to have you back in las
vegas what can we expect this weekend
you have so much going on what do you
have going on this weekend well apart
from the car show which is the biggest
one of the biggest car shows of its type
because every car is built before 1964.
there's over 60 live bands all doing 50
style rock and roll and rockabilly we
got vendors there's burlesque shows
let's take a look at some of the cars
yeah what kind of vendors are gonna be
out here this weekend well all the
vendors are connected to the scene so it
could be t-shirts vintage clothing it'd
be car parts it could be hair pomade
i need some of that right now
and then you're going to have also
there's going to be pool parties
happening i mean you guys are taking
over the orleans everything pool parties
bowling events too yeah we've got
bowling events and even we take over the
pa system inside the casino so all
you're hearing is 50 star rock and roll
and rockabilly i i i noticed it when i
came to hotel i got the vibe with the
rockability now as far as the car show
the car show is happening today uh
friday saturday but like the events with
this with the bands that's all on
saturday all on saturday saturday's the
big day
someone's watching right now and they've
got a car pretty much 60 what pre-1964
period correct 364. they want to enter
can people still enter the cars because
these vehicles are stunning out here yes
they can turn up and as long as we've
got space then they can come in now
there's going to be like burlesque
fashion shows and burlesque contests
going on yes yeah but it's burlesque
competition there's a bowler showcase
and we have burlesque bingo also too uh
are there weddings taking place oh yeah
just over there there's a wedding chapel
where on saturday there'll be weddings
all day what are some of the uh this we
saw the stage behind us you guys were
getting set up what are some of the
bands are gonna be out here this weekend
at the car show there's gonna be big
sand in the fly right boys the surfer
jets there's the go-getters from sweden
and the rhythm shakers from california
spit around here last year right i got
to wrap it up you just shot one more
shot of this car here look at the
station wagon over there
that's nice what's a rockabilly term i
can wrap things up with like that's
right daddy oh like what's uh give me
that
we turn up to use terms like that
las vegas i'll send it back to you guys
in the studio thanks dadio